how do you use Alibaba people say
China's largest e-commerce site is like
Amazon eBay and PayPal all rolled into
one
but while Alibaba does have subsidiaries
focused on mobile payments data storage
and online shopping its original site is
dedicated to connecting businesses with
other businesses let me show you so many
of today's consumer products are
designed developed and built in China
and what Alibaba comm does is directly
connect businesses around the world to
those self-same Chinese manufacturers
creating millions of wholesaler retailer
relationships let's say you're a small
American store looking to buy a bunch of
affordable alarm clocks you go to the
site and type in alarm clocks like you
would on Amazon what's different here is
there's no price tag leaving you to
haggle or bid off Craigslist half eBay
once you've chosen an alarm clock you
like you can either contact the supply
directly or bid with a payment to see if
they can match your budget if they can
your payment leaves an escrow account
you've deposited the money in but
there's usually a minimum order size for
economies of scale that leaves the
profits higher for the seller and the
shipping margins lower for the buyer oh
and clearing those alarm clocks through
US Customs that's entirely up to you